a group of protesters many appear to be
veterans wearing military attire
dismantle fencing surrounding the war
memorial fencing put up after this scene
during the first weekend of the protest
police are still investigating
[Music]
as the crowd around the memorial swelled
on saturday at first only a couple of
police officers were visible outnumbered
they talked to the dismantlers about
their cause a statement saying to the
politicians that
the soldiers don't see in them are
representatives because
we're portraying our country at this
point in time
protesters cleared the steps of snow and
yelled to watch out for the flowers
placed there good point we're going to
be back at the same point where people
are now going to
uh cause damage because unless you guys
are here 24 7
i actually don't think you would be the
people that cause damage it's going to
be justin trudeau and his gang of
thieves yes and if we're going to put a
man on this because you guys have what
like a thousand cops in the city right
now so that's not what you guys are
saying so we'll put a man on it next one
this is all you guys
the veterans affairs minister called
what happened completely unacceptable
ottawa police wouldn't answer any of our
questions about it but they did speak to
the theme of being outnumbered in a
release earlier saturday they said they
have a plan to end what they're calling
an illegal occupation but they need more
reinforcements to carry it out
everybody's here peacefully protesters
in ottawa have been watching a different
scene in windsor where enforcement to
move people out began saturday morning
no one we spoke to seems worried i
honestly want to see every all the
protesters on their knees with their
hands up getting arrested right because
we're here peacefully for my nephew's
freedom for the next generation of kids
freedom
i'll take a fine i'll get arrested i'm
not afraid police say 2600 tickets have
been issued and they've made 26 arrests
with 140 criminal investigations
underway as many call for tougher action
with thousands in the streets of the
nation's capital for the third weekend
in a row abigail beeman global news
ottawa